let his clock run out because it's a
hopeless position anyway what a dramatic
start to the oslo esports cup you guys
the bar been shifting from side to side
but eventually magnus carlsen wins game
one in his match against john christoph
duda a dramatic match we see magnus
walking
out towards
the lounge will we see a smile on his
face it's a great great start for him he
still looks quite focused and young
christophe duda is coming right behind
him we're going to check if magnus will
stop
he does
yeah it was uh very interesting um
i think uh
well i thought i had a good position at
first when i sucked the exchange
but i couldn't find um
continuation that gave me uh gave me an
advantage maybe um maybe i missed
something early on i don't know uh and
then
uh
yeah he kind of outplayed me at some
point and i was a bit worse
but it seemed like i was holding a draw
and then towards the end with little
time he uh
i don't know yeah i i think um
the position shifted a bit as soon as i
i got my puns running then i couldn't
lose
and yeah it went very uh quickly
downhill from
frame from there which was a bit
surprising but
nevertheless um a good win
david was confident on dude's behalf
when he had the uneven material because
he likes those positions how do you feel
about that yeah i knew that i was
playing a bit into his hands but i
thought it was the correct way to play
and that trumps everything does it
um not always but i thought in in this
case you know i mean the first game of
um of the tournament it's it's not the
time to deduct the challenge good luck
thank you
michael see